[Music]
hi everyone my name's Natalie and we are
here in the G suite demo booth and I'm
joined here by Ricard who's from Gant a
customer who had an amazing digital
transformation with G Suites welcome
thank you thank you very much tell us a
little bit about Gant and how you opened
up a new store with G suite in three
months amazing its account is a fashion
brand
we're headquarters in Stockholm today
we're an old company was actually born
in USA from the beginning one of the
things that we did is we brought the
button-down shirt to the market so a
couple of years ago we had a challenge
where we had to open up a new street a
new store on Regent Street in London and
we had a record amount of we have to do
it in a record amount time so we usually
what usually takes one year we had to do
in three months we have to work fast so
we've actually got Whitney here as well
who's going to take us through a demo is
that right here we have a cool video of
the London store actually being built
out by the team and as they were
planning they had a lot of documents
going around they needed to be able to
get everyone on the same page working on
the same document moving quickly
together and so they used to send file
versions back and forth all the time and
they really really slowed down the
process so they switched to Google Docs
and using Google Docs they were all able
to work together on the same document in
all the different teams across their
locations and they were able to comment
each other in to assign tasks get inputs
from team members across all different
locations and able to just really move
quickly together because they were all
running in that same
we're gonna move now from our London
store team to the Stockholm headquarters
team okay so now you're going to show us
what the Stockholm team was doing the
inventory planning right yes exactly so
we've just moved into the Stockholm
headquarters where the team was also
working really hard to prepare for the
London store opening and they were
focused mostly on planning all of the
inventory that was going to be needed
for the new store and so in order to do
that they needed everyone working on the
same spreadsheet planning what was going
on planning where the clothes were
coming from how much we needed of each
item things like that and the same way
with Docs that they were all able to
collaborate live on that one document
they were able to do the same thing on
the spreadsheet which helped them move
really quickly as well and they also
used a feature called sheets Explorer
which allows people to ask questions
about their data in natural language so
they can get insights from their data
like what's the average price for
quantity and things like that and that
way they're able to get all the
information they need to plan really
effectively but it's through actually
asking through voice those types of
questions it's it's awesome because a
lot of people kind of businesses don't
necessarily know how to write sequel or
complex queries the sheet explorer toy
is amazing for them yeah no longer do we
have the headaches of creating all the
pivot tables yeah and writing you can
just go in and get those insights from
your data right away great ok now we're
going to imagine we're in another
country
we've made it to Portugal where the
Gantt manufacturing facility is located
quick trip and so the team here was
working really hard to create all of the
clothing that was going to be needed for
the store and so they were hard at work
in the manufacturing facility really to
make the best items they could but they
needed to get approvals from the London
and the Stockholm teams who we're doing
the designs and wanted to make sure it
was the quality they were looking for
and things like that and
times those decisions just need to be
made face-to-face yeah exactly and so
the gap team used to fly people to the
manufacturing facilities to check out
the clothing make sure it all looked
good but now they've really switched to
using meat which is G sweets video
conferencing solution and using meat
they're able to get everyone in the same
room virtually so they can still see the
look and the feel of the clothing and so
now I'm actually gonna have the
opportunity to show you how they would
do that so we're already hooked into
this meeting on our computer and I'm
going to show you how the team in the
manufacturing facility is able to join
with one click from the phone and then
they actually will walk around with the
phone and join the meeting and be able
to see the clothing get a feel for it
and this way get all of the approvals
they need for the clothing amazing so
it's you know you get the feeling that
you're actually in Porto although you're
in sperm or London that's amazing well
thank you so much for this walk around
this has definitely been one of the most
interactive sessions and demonstrations
thanks Whitney
and Ricard also I guess you know the G
suite technology is amazing but I I'm
assuming this just meant so much for
your customers to be able to move from
producing a store in one year to three
months
it did it was a wreckin time and we
ended up with happy customers definitely
I'd imagine you did Thank You sorry much
boys there for joining us
[Music]